il est 17 heures au péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines jour de
départs des vacances d'été environ
soixante-dix mille véhicules sont
attendus pour ce vendredi 8 juillet et
au centre d'information trafic les
superviseurs veille sur la circulation
autoroutière
nous avons des informations qui sont
principalement relayés par nos
patrouilleurs qui circulent 24 heures
sur 24 sur notre réseau ces informations
la redescente vers les centres
d'exploitation qui rédige en fait des
fiches d'information vers le centre
d'information trafic avant que ça parte
sur la diffusion des panneaux à messages
variables et de radio vinci autoroutes
sur ses écrans les vignettes
représentent les panneaux à messages
variables sur l'autoroute du grand ouest
je collecte les informations qui émanent
du réseau pour pouvoir après affichés
sur les panneaux à messages variables à
un événement qui arrive en direct j'ai
un bouchon sur nantes
donc voilà je permet de visualiser
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui se passe
à l'heure actuelle donc on a un bouchon
qui augmente en arrivant sur le
périphérique nantais localisation nombre
de véhicules concernés et causes de
l'incident
toutes ces informations sont envoyées
aux ses hits et pour permettre d'évaluer
les conséquences sur le trafic
plusieurs types de dangers peuvent
intervenir c'est souvent soit des pertes
de chargement mal arrimé sur la route
soit des distances de sécurité du fait
du trafic qui est relativement dense qui
sont mal à respecter et des coups de
frein brutaux qui parfois occasionne pas
forcément des accidents très important
mais qui ont des conséquences en terme
de fluidité relativement sensible au
total près de 4 millions
d'automobilistes devrait emprunter le
péage de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
durant la période estivale